I am thrilled to kick off our week at
comic-con by celebrating the 10th
anniversary of their premiere of one of
the greatest shows in television history
please welcome the creator of Breaking
Bad Vince Gilligan and stars
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's amazing
that was that's what they love it Turner
is any show where we throw meth into the
crowd those are the kind of values we
got here welcome all of you this is
- all right it's time good night
everybody
this is really exciting to see the power
that this show still has over us ten
years after it started is absolutely
incredible
now I have to say a lot of shows that
get the kind of a claim that Breaking
Bad had when they come to the finale
they take a lot of hits I thought it was
incredible Breaking Bad universally
acclaim for the finale is in this right
Vince by everybody except yes except
your mom yeah yeah my mom that's her
Gail Gilligan who's watching this she's
gonna be giving me all Kassadin rafter
come on made it through mr. fantastic
mooning me I think she's she tuned out a
long time ago so speak freely about your
mouth okay that's good to know
now she I'm not sure she would ever
watch Breaking Bad in the first place if
I hadn't been involved because she's you
know she's just a sweet nice lady who is
you know doesn't want to see the bad guy
prevail in a TV show at the end of
Breaking Bad she said I really wanted
Walt to get away with it I wanted I want
another white to get away early
scot-free half free yeah so she's you
know I know you knew my mom you would
say yeah what is the normal kind of show
that she watches on television she
watched a lot of homework channel stuff
and that's what she watches and then her
son makes breaking maybe Walter why did
get away with it maybe he did
though there was no poor it's actually
it's right if that had been any other
bet have been a you know horror many
other horror movie do you don't I mean a
Jason movie just him lying there that's
meaningless was there a coroner's report
there was no coroner's report outing no
fascinating was there a listing in the
obituaries yeah it sounds like Cranston
needs work I know that's it
you